for federal contractors with
disabilities and restore minimum wage
protections to outfitters and guides
operating on federal lands uh
also as you uh may remember and i think
this announcement just went out but
president
biden signed america executive order
directing federal agencies to ensure
taxpayer dollars supporting american
manufacturing
we've been of course hard at work
delivering on that commitment and today
the president announced the appointment
of celeste drake as the nation's first
made in america director which i think
is a great title
as made in america director with the uh
within the office of management and
budget
she will make sure agencies follow the
president's ambitious bi-american
commitment and will help continue the
work to carry out his bold
made in america agenda
also today sorry two more items here uh
thanks to the american rescue plan uh
the department of homeland
of health and human services is
announcing the availability of one
billion dollars
for the construction and renovation of
community health centers
the funding builds on president biden's
commitment to ensuring
equity and access to covet 19 response
efforts
and high quality primary health care
services community health centers are a
critical pipeline as we've talked about
a bit in here before
for our covet 19 vaccination efforts and
all over the nation's nearly 1400
health resources and services
administration funded health centers
will be eligible for
these funds finally
following the president's address to the
joint session of congress
we are launching the getting america
back on track
tour to highlight the successes of the
first hundred days and addressing the
crises facing our country
vaccinating america to beat the pandemic
200 million more than 200 million
americans to be exact
delivering much needed financial help to
american families making transformative
investments
to rescue and rebuild our economy and
fundamentally showing the government can
deliver
for people they'll also will also use
the tour to take the case directly the
american people about the vital need
for action on the jobs plan and the
families plan which the president will
be
laying out in detail tomorrow evening so
we can make badly needed investments in
the financial security
of middle-class families as well as in
jobs growth and competitiveness
after the joint session the president
vice president first lady second
gentleman
and cabinet members will fan out across
the country on thursday
as you know the president and first lady
will travel to georgia and
the vice president will go to baltimore
on friday the president will travel to
philadelphia pennsylvania
the vice president will go to ohio and
the second gentleman will head to north
carolina
they will be traveling of course next
week as well and we will announce
additional stops
then hello josh go ahead kick us off
thanks much jen
um the census recently came out and
reallocated congressional seats
does the white house share the concerns
that hispanics were under counted as
part of the census
well first let me say that the president
took steps
when he took office to overturn the
policies of the trump administration or
the approach to counting
by the trump administration that was one
of the first steps he took
as you know this process is carried out
by career
apolitical experts it was announced
yesterday because they needed additional
time and we thought that was
absolutely appropriate of course the
steps that are taken to allocate
congressional seats is set by statute
and has been in place since 1941.
in terms of the impact of the last
administration i would send you to the
census we're not in a position to assess
that secondly a report came out today
from human rights watch
about israel saying that israel is
guilty of international crimes of
apartheid
and persecution because of
discriminatory policies for palestinians
israel has rejected that
characterization
does the white house think the report is
accurate or inaccurate
well uh joshua state's apartment has its
own rigorous process for making
atrocity determinations and reports on
human rights abuse
issues globally on an annual basis
through the human rights report that
they issue
they do briefings on and they put out
publicly the department has never
used such terminology as to the question
of whether
israel's actions constitute apartheid
that is not the view of this
administration
uh go ahead is the thank you is the
president going to change his own
personal habits to
adapt to the new cdc guidelines uh
certainly he'll be
following public health guidelines so i
think you saw him outside today he took
the mask off he didn't put the mask back
on
it will take some time to adjust and
adapt for all of us and
i know when i take my kids to the
playground this weekend i'll be happy
not to be wearing a mask
what about indoors is he changing
anything about indoors
uh well the the guidance as you know
that was put out um it was more about
mask wearing outside if you're
vaccinated and you can and you wear a
mask inside then
you can go to gyms and restaurants and
things along those lines
we will still in here until there's
different guidelines abide by
the recommendations of the cdc as it
relates to workplaces
you talk a little bit about the speech
tomorrow how long do you think it'll be
is he doing practice sessions
um are cabinet members going to be in
attendance
for that sort of thing sure let me give
you as many details as they can
at this point and then we'll continue to
provide additional updates as you all
know there's a briefing later tonight
as well um first steve you have covered
many presidents who've delivered these
addresses uh you can be our historian
and tell us if any of them have final
addresses where we know the exact length
about 36 hours in advance so we're not
quite there on that piece yet
but i can tell you that the president
has been working
on this speech for the last few weeks he
has been
preparing with um senior advisor mike
donald
director of speech writing vinai reddy
working on the speech and really over
the last several days he's been
edit line editing it meeting with his
speech writers getting
advice and counsel from senior advisors
checking in with members of his family
and also as part of his process he
engages with his policy teams to
ask for additional details ask for
further clarification
and certainly given we're rolling out
the american families plan that has also
been
uh being been finalized or in the
finalization process through this
i can also tell you that while the major
policy announcement in the speech is of
course the american
family's plan a historic investment in
education and child care he will also
use the speech
as an opportunity to talk about many of
his other priorities
including police reform immigration gun
safety his ongoing work to get the
pandemic under control
and to putting americans back to work uh
he was in the senate for 36 years he
also
sat through eight of these as the vice
president and he certainly recognizes
the important opportunity that this
offers uh
in in attendance uh there will be uh the
secretary of state and the secretary of
defense as well as i think the supreme
court confirmed the chief justice will
be in attendance
joining him will be dr biden the vice
president and of course the second
gentleman there will not be a first
ladies
box as there has been historically
while the speech will of course look and
feel different from past years
the president will preserve a few
traditions including the walk down the
center aisle
that we have seen presidents do for many
years you of course be wearing a mask
for that he'll remove the mask when he
delivers
uh his speech he'll also um be meeting
uh with uh men and women a career staff
who are at the capitol on january 6th in
advance of the speech
will he bring you know i know he'll have
a foreign policy piece will there be a
lot of talk about china in this speech
i expect there certainly will be a
foreign policy speech it's never as much
foreign policy as the foreign policy
team wants that's always the battle but
um there will be a foreign policy
portion of the speech he will talk about
um our his commitment to uh re-engaging
with the world
taking america's seat back in the world
what our values are as a country
and certainly i would expect he'll talk
about a number of the priorities of this
administration including our engagement
with china
uh go ahead peter just for clarity since
the whole cabinet isn't going to be
there in the past there would be a
designated survivor if they say is there
a designated survivor on a night like
tomorrow night and who would that be
there does not need to be a designated
survivor because the cabinet will be
watching uh from their offices or home
um but they will not be
joining him for the speech ranking
person who's not present there but i
guess we'll sort that out for ourselves
thereafter let me ask you about the
president's remarks earlier
obviously this white house's
administration has spent so much time
trying to get americans
to wear masks
fully vaccinated are there concerns that
this could cause in some form of
resurgence or
that this relies on the outer system and
thereby could cause any uptick
in cobia well peter i think one of the
priorities of the presidents and the
vice presidents in our entire team of
course is abiding by health and medical
experts and guidance
but is providing information transparent
information to the public
to make clear what the benefit
have no fear the ceiling is not falling
but i'm aware of okay
um okay hopefully it's an old building
um one maybe lincoln's ghost
that's quite something maybe it is um uh
one of the president's priorities is um
ensuring people understand who are
vaccinated out there who are
contemplating whether they should get
vaccinated
what the benefits are and uh well we
will of course
always abide by the health and medical
advice of our experts the cdc guidelines
on this this is a step forward
um because people can go out and they
can take their kids to the park and not
wear masks if it's not crowded
you can go for a run that's what they're
telling you and that's safe if you're
vaccinated
uh and uh and not wear a mask and you
know this is important for people to
hear as well so we're trying
we're at the stage now where we have
enough supply we want to convey to
people what the benefits are and this
these are
some of the benefits on the july 4th
deadline that the president had her goal
that the president said in his
inaugural prime time address from here
at the white house he said if we do this
together by july 4th there's a good
chance that you your friends and family
can have
can get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood and have a cookout or
a barbecue
and celebrate independence day
we didn't we sort of erased that
deadline in some ways
doesn't say right now for those backside
that day is
here well i think it's clear that as it
has been clear for some time he's also
the guidelines from the cdc
several weeks ago was also if your
neighbors are vaccinated
uh you can be inside and have dinner
with them what he's trying to convey to
the public
is when the vaccine is available when he
made that announcement
when the vaccine is broadly available
which it now is to the public as of
april 19th
encourage your friends to get vaccinated
encourage your neighbors to get
vaccinated we know that that's one of
the most
impactful ways to get people to
pharmacies to their doctor's office to
do that
so we can have a barbecue on july 4th so
yes we are there are some communities
some people whose neighbors are
vaccinated they can all gather
if there's a you know april 30th
barbecue but
for some but not for all is the point
well the incentive is to get vaccinated
so that you can enjoy the benefits of
being vaccinated
let me ask you if i can really quickly
about as it relates to
nova backs and to astrazeneca the white
house said that it would be providing 60
million doses
to other countries has the
administration communicated to
astrazeneca
or to and to nova backs that they don't
need to rush
ahead of their effort to get a eua right
now
yeah you're going to be giving it
elsewhere well first
i think we see that as a separate
process they have not applied
for an eua and nora obviously have they
been granted one
we also have uh ordered 300 million
doses from astrazeneca which we
certainly expect they will
deliver on so uh we will evaluate what
we're talking about here is
the reason 300 million is relevant is
because we're talking about 60 million
here
10 of which we expect and hope will be
through the fda review in the next few
weeks and the
50 million in the next few months uh
but you know they will decide when they
apply for an eu we're talking about
doses that have not yet been approved
that we are going to supply uh to give
to the global community
thank you sort of a broader
all of government kind of question a
year ago this week
it was said in this room how sunlight
might kill the virus and make outdoor
transmission unlikely
clearly things are a little different
now but why
have americans had to wait this long for
today's guidance
when to many it was quite obvious that
this was what
the next step was well ed i think we
want americans to be confident
in the information they're receiving
from the federal government
it's been important to us to lead with
health and medical experts
to provide them the time they need to
make these evaluations
uh so that when the cdc comes out with
guidance
the american people know they can trust
it and you know we're
we we are working to uh clean up from
a great deal of misinformation
inaccurate information
that was put out by the last
administration some of it politically
tinged
and uh it's therefore we we've been
really leading into the timeline
of the health and medical team and
experts if there's anyone out there who
questions whether this decision coming
right before the big speech and right
before the 100 days
you guys would say i i can assure you
that the cdc makes uh
makes decisions and does evaluations on
their own timeline
things can you confirm whether the
administration still plans to buy
a hundred million more doses of johnson
johnson's vaccine
i don't think anything has changed about
our plans no idea why there's a delay
then
a delay in their delivery or a delay in
uh purchasing
both i'll have to i'll check on that for
you guys uh why
the india decision this week and the
president just spoke to him why was it a
similar
announcement to some resources or help
made when brazil
had its outbreak earlier this year and
we know they too were sort of
collaborating for
international assistance uh well ed i
can speak to kind of where we are
as a obviously we're a provider as you
know of a great deal of public health
assistance to india but also to brazil
um our focus our availability at this
point of providing
certain kinds of resources including uh
the materials to make vaccine may not
have been at that point
several months ago uh but i'd have to
talk to our team about what the specific
requests were and what they feel were
not met
and i'm asking this one on behalf of our
miami tv station you may have seen this
report about a private school
in miami that's telling its staff and
teachers not to get the covert vaccine
they're threatening to terminate their
employment if they do get it
these teachers are being forced to
choose between their job
and their health obviously there's not
much the white house specifically can do
does it have any comment on this
situation and
any idea if there's anything federal
authorities can do to help the teachers
in this case
that's a good question in terms of
helping the teachers i'll have to check
with the department of education i'd
send you to them as well of course
obviously our objective is continuing to
convey
that it's important to abide by public
health guidelines that they're in place
for a reason that they are not
done through a political prism they are
done by medical experts by health
experts
intended to keep children safe keep
parents safe keep teachers safe keep
communities safe
which is why we recommend people abide
by them go ahead
thanks john i want to start with a
follow-up on the coveted vaccines
specifically the astrazeneca doses that
are going abroad
i want to clarify something you said
yesterday about kovacs
and you just say whether the u.s is
considering distributing those doses to
other countries
through kovacs or are you only focusing
on distributing them
on country by country basis directly we
expect it to be a combination
um it is uh we're still developing our
plants
and what that looks like and again as i
alluded to earlier
we're talking about about 10 million
doses if it is goes through fda review
in the next few weeks so it's not today
we have zero doses available today
and then another 15 million in several
months so we have some time to develop
what our plan is and
meet uh whatever the needs are at that
moment in time
and then on refugees the washington post
reported today that there's now
consideration
of bumping that cap up to the 63
500 number that the administration
initially proposed in february
your statement at the time would when
that was changed that
leaving that target was unlikely so can
you just talk about
what changed in the thinking there again
as as this consideration is leading up
to may 15.
sure well we've we've long said uh or
said for the last several weeks that
uh the president had every intention of
announcing a cap
a new cap um and that he would do that
in advance of may 15th and we are
certainly continue to be on track
toward that uh in terms of our
considerations over time
we inherited an incredibly broken system
uh it left us with some in the president
others with some skepticism about what
the system
would bear hence our announcement a
couple of weeks ago was meant to be a
first step
focused on announcing the resumption of
flights uh
and also the overturning of the
xenophobic policies of the last
administration that prevented
refugees from applying from africa and
the middle east
uh that has changed that was the biggest
hindrance to refugees being able to
apply
from that part of the world or in
general but from that part of the world
one of the considerations at this point
in time as we're determining what the
cap will look like is
uh what message we're sending to the
world and we are a country
under the biden harris administration
where we want to send a clear message we
are welcoming refugees
we want to send that message to the
world we want to send that message to
the refugee community and to
organizations that have been
underfunded that have had their muscles
atrophied over the past couple of years
where that was not a primary focus
uh we also are sending want to send a
message that we are
the president has long been committed to
the 125 000
cap that he has set has always
consistently been his objective since
february
for the next fiscal year 62 5 was always
meant to be
a down payment on that uh and so
those are the considerations as we make
a determination about the cap that we're
setting
but would you now say getting to that
62-5 number
this fiscal year is likely rather than
unlikely
i would say that whatever the cap is if
the cap is close to that or at that it
will continue to be challenging but
there are considerations including the
message we're sending to the world
uh and also the need to get the muscles
working
in the system in the federal government
but also with all of the important
partners out there in the united states
and around the world
that play an important role in refugees
traveling to the united states
i'll help enable them to raise money
help enable them to
hire staff and get their systems ready
so we can meet that 125 cap next year
go ahead on india and the explosion of
covenant cases there the uk and canada
have already instituted a travel ban
in regards to india why isn't the us
doing the same
we would make those determinations based
on the advice of our health and medical
team
they haven't made that determination at
this point and we are hearing reports of
places where vaccine supply is
outstripping demand
in iowa for instance they're now
defining a new shipment
a vaccine because the demand isn't there
if this continues
would the administration consider
shipping more doses overseas
well we always expect it to hit that
point and we're in a new stage
at this point in time as you alluded to
mary where
uh there are we're not we don't have a
supply challenge now our challenge is
ensuring we're meeting people where they
are
we're getting into these communities
we're in uh continuing to increase
confidence which we've seen and
increasing in a range of communities
black and brown communities as well as
more conservative white communities
which is a good sign
but there's more work to be done uh we
will continue to
evaluate what supply we have available
for the global community and we want to
be a part of that effort as is evidenced
by the announcement we made
yesterday but that doesn't mean we're
going to pull back
on uh or provide give away supply that
is needed to vaccinate the american
people because that remains our top
priority
uh go ahead in the back i had one on
labor relations and then one on the
virus if i could um the national labor
relations board has a may
hearing uh caught a complaint from the
retail wholesale and department store
union they allege that amazon kind of
interfered
in that union push and vote down in
alabama does president biden feel that
amazon did in fact interfere does he
support to complain
we would leave that to the nlrb they're
in place for a reason
you expect that just play out
i know the virus um i know we're still
fighting covid but
what efforts are put to make the u.s
more proactive if another pandemic
comes along down the road um you know be
more nimble in testing surveillance
i know he proposed that darpa like
agency
rph yeah would it infect this disease to
be part of that um is he gonna address
this at the speech
just looking down the road what might
come
arpa-h is an issue in an endeavor that
is close to the president's heart he's
talked about it
quite a bit it could be a part of the
speech but we're still finalizing what
that
looks like i will say that one of the
president's objectives and the objective
of our national security team is to do
exactly what you said is to
prepare for uh any future pandemics to
make sure we are
more closely working with our national
partners international partners around
the world
that we are fully staffing agencies and
positions
that were removed during the prior
administration that we are investing in
research and development and that we are
leading with health and science
so uh we are while we are fighting this
pandemic
we are also focused on re-investing in
areas to prevent next pandemic including
personnel research
and any needs to do exactly that go
ahead
hey um so just a question uh obviously
the president is going to celebrate the
100 day mark with this tour
so looking ahead to the next hundred
days for sure administration
the first 100 days were quite scripted
you know the transition team talked
quite a bit about
how they you know fighting set out
certain goals for them and they
tried to meet those over the course of
the first hundred days what does the
next 100 days
look like can you give us some sort of
preview of what new
parties or benchmarks you're going to
set and how that planning process
is is is underway well first
we certainly believe we're still going
to uh be at war with
the virus um and there's more work to be
done to
uh get the virus under control to meet
people where they are to
get people vaccinated who may not be
confident in the efficacy at this point
in time that will be a
continue to be a priority uh we are
continuing to implement the american
jobs plan uh and the american or sorry
we're continuing to
implement the american restaurant i got
a little ahead of myself there uh we
will be working with congress
closely by part in a bipartisan way is
certainly our intention
to get the american jobs plan passed to
get the american families plan passed
the president would like to see
progress by memorial day and would like
to sign it into law this summer so that
will those will certainly be
big priorities of our next hundred days
uh he also believes that uh
police reform getting the george floyd
justice and policing act passed
is long overdue and he would certainly
like to see that
move forward in congress and and we've
just
last week we just held a i'm not done
yet we last week we just held an
international climate summit there was a
lot of due outs and a lot of work to be
done from that
and i expect we'll continue to charge
forward on addressing the climate crisis
and just should we expect more
benchmarks obviously he set the 200
million in 100 days
majority of schools reopened in 100 days
is that sort of a
a pace that we'll see so those sort of
benchmarks said again
for the next hundred days do you have i
expect we're going to continue to set
marking points in a transparent way
so that we can evaluate ourselves and
the american people can evaluate our
progress
and just one more on the travel i know
you've said more travel to come but one
of the things about
the president travel so far has mostly
been to states that he won um
as to cover his campaign and he talked
quite a bit there are blue states around
red state
should we expect the president to travel
to states
uh more states that he did not win in
the presidential election or not
traditional
battleground states yes stay tuned
any updates on what this might be i'm
not going to tell you before we tell
governors
so soon um go ahead thank you in
addition to messaging the benefits of
the vaccine launching the community core
what other strategies is the
administration considering to reach out
to the vaccine hesitant since that
seemed hesitant the remaining 50
well i would say first we've seen a
great deal of improvement
along these lines when the president
took office it was
you know only about 40 of the public
wanted to get and take the vaccine
that has increased dramatically uh since
that point in time
we've seen increases in confidence in
among black and brown communities we've
also seen increases in confidence among
white conservative communities which i
reference those because those are some
of the communities where there has been
a higher level of
of hesitation but what our focus is on
is
is following the data so what we've seen
is that local messengers trusted voices
doctors medical experts civic leaders
clergy
and local communities continuing to
distribute out that three billion
dollars that
has part of our funding to get to those
communities
is is going to be priced front and
center to our strategy so we're
continuing to
uh implement uh exactly that and one of
the challenges we've seen or heard most
from communities or people who are
reluctant to take the vaccine is access
and the challenge of taking
a day off of work or fitting it into
their lives some of that is
again meeting people where they are
mobile clinics local doctors
you know making it available at
pharmacies uh but some of it is also
uh the paid leave announcement we made
just last week for businesses of under
500 that they can that people can get
time off and have that
covered through paid leave in order to
go get a vaccine shot so there are a
number of
uh strategies we're implementing we're
seeing progress we're seeing them work
and we know it will continue to be
harder as we vaccinate more and more
people
is the administration tracking unused
doses
in each state and what's being done to
make sure in
individual jurisdictions doses are not
going wasted
certainly we are our cova team is and
certainly they work with states
localities
through our pharmacy program and all of
our programs to ensure we're doing
everything possible to ensure doses are
used
and one more on behalf of radio pool is
there an update on whether the us will
support the special waiver to weigh
vaccine patents at the wto
so other countries can make generic
versions
of course there's a meeting at the end
of the month and i know that uh
our ambassador our usd and our ustr uh
spoke to this
so uh how we're looking at this is our
focus is on
uh maximizing production and supply at
the
in in for the world at the lowest
possible cost and there are a lot of
different ways to do that
um right now that's one of one of the
ways
but we have to assess uh what makes the
most sense so for example
we produce a lot of vaccines here in the
united states right vaccines
you know manufactured here we have
manufacturing facilities that have been
through a number of them
have been through fda approval or going
through fda approval uh we have to
evaluate whether it's more effective to
manufacture here
and provide supply to the world or the
ip waiver is an option there has not
been a recommendation made from ustr nor
has the president made a decision
and one more follow-up on that topic
what will go into deciding which
countries get our excess vaccine
well expect it will be a combination of
our covid team
working with our national security team
our team at the state department
to determine where the requests are
where the needs come in uh
where the needs are uh in order and when
we're we can
maybe the most impactful on helping get
the pandemic under control
uh and there is a process ongoing now
again we'll have about 10 million doses
we expect hopefully
if they go through the fda review in the
next couple of weeks and then
an additional 50 several months from
there
go ahead is the white house open to some
of the changes that senator scott
has proposed on a qualified immunity
in particular is the white house open to
making it so that
lawsuits can be brought against police
departments as opposed to just
police officers well the white house and
the president
are strong supporters of the george
floyd justice and policing act that has
passed the house
we have every confidence in the
negotiations that are happening
between members of the house and the
senate and we will make an evaluation
once those hopefully conclude
uh go ahead thanks jen two questions
first
on the on the virus and related to the
uh the
the new guidance on the masks yeah this
means that there will also be a revision
to the president's order on mask
use in federal facilities for instance
will the national park service
be easing the guidelines for the where
you have to wear a mask when you're
outside on a trail
or at an overlook in the national park
or anything like that
yeah it's a great question uh just like
many states will be looking at
the new guidance i know obviously
federal entities will be very closely
looking at the guidance i will have to
check and see what the status of that is
but
obviously federal agencies the national
park service and others
certainly look at um and the president
looks at the guidance
put out by the cdc and expect there'll
be adjustments accordingly
but we'll have to check on the status of
those or timeline
uh and on another topic uh it's it's
been probably about a week i think since
someone in this room is asked the
question about the student loan
uh forgiveness or cancellation uh i know
that the department
of energy department of education was
working on
some sort of uh review of what was
possible
is that review going to be something
that will be completed in time
uh to make uh chuck schumer a very happy
senator tomorrow night
or is that something that we'll have to
wait a little while longer the review is
ongoing
uh hopefully uh we will make senator
leader schumer happy in other ways
in the speech but um the review
in is ongoing thank you julian uh so two
questions my first one a follow-up to
this one i understand the
that you will be um that the covet team
and the national security team are going
to consider for the vaccine
sharing i understand we still don't have
any
asteroids that got those to share but
the 10 million
millions that will be coming can you at
least say that
in order to open more quickly
the borders with mexico and canada they
will be
at the top of the list of the countries
who will have access to these banks
i can't um you know obviously we have
already
lent doses to canada and mexico they are
important they're not only our neighbors
they are our friends
but the process is just beginning and i
don't want to get ahead of the process
that will be
uh the ongoing process once it's
concluded we'll let you know
okay thank you i i i want to try john's
question again
about the human right um the um
uh the human right watch report
on the treatment of palestinians by
israel
um and the abuse is that they underlined
it's a very thorough report
you said um and and the fact that the
u.s
has turned a blind night to what's
happening over there that's what they
say that's what they say
uh you said that in the forum in this
in the present speech tomorrow there's
going to be a foreign policy
uh section and he's going to talk about
what are our values do you consider that
the treatment of palestinians
by israel correspond to the american
background well i would say
that the united states is committed to
promoting respect for human rights in
israel and the west bank and the gaza
strip
and even during partner we also have an
enduring partnership with israel and
discuss a wide range of issues with the
israeli government
including those related to human rights
so
i was really conveying or responding
specifically to josh's question but it's
important to reiterate that so
appreciate giving me the opportunity to
do that go ahead
good afternoon just a few questions for
you has the president decided who he
wants to see
serve as the next u.s ambassador to the
holy see
and what are his criteria in choosing
that person
i don't have any personnel announcements
to make i know that's of course an
important one
but i uh we've announced just a couple
of ambassadors and hopefully we'll have
more in the coming months we will have
more in the coming months
would you pick someone pro-life would
you pick someone pro-life
i don't have any more details on who the
president may or may not pick for
uh that important role next question uh
as you well know the administration just
lifted the ban
on researchers using fetal tissue from
elective abortions in the us conference
of catholic bishops
the leaders of the president's own faith
said in reaction
it is deeply offensive quote to millions
of americans for our tax dollars to be
used for research that collaborates with
an industry built
on the taking of innocent lives how does
the white house respond to that
criticism
look i think the white house specific or
respectfully disagrees
and we believe that it's important to
invest in science and
look for opportunities to cure diseases
and i think that this is hopeful to do
go ahead okay third question
i've been here 12. research sure
okay uh you may be aware of the uh the
lgbtq
lgbtq community is suing the us
department of education
saying they say their religious
exemption rule under title ix
is unconstitutional i'm not familiar
with that case
but what is the administration's
response to that in other words will you
stand behind
that religious exemption i'll have to
check with our legal team and in general
generally speaking
we support lgbtq rights and believe that
especially for children and children
should be able to play sports
including children and members of the
lgbtq community of course
religious exemption the white house
stands behind i don't have anything more
on it i'll check with our team go ahead
thanks jen i wanted to follow up first
on qualified immunity
is the president committed to signing
policing
legislation if that bipartisan
working group that includes karen bass
and tim scott
are able to come to an agreement get
something passed in congress is he
committed to signing that
well he has every trust and confidence
in uh karen bass and appreciates the
work of senator booker senator scott as
well
uh he again is a supporter of the
george floyd justice and policing act
that has passed the house and we're not
going to negotiate from here we'll
see what comes through their
negotiations and as far as his speech
tomorrow to the joint session of
congress is concerned i heard you
earlier talked about some of the folks
who had been involved in helping him
right back
did the vice president help him write
that anyway review any parts of that how
is she involved in a speech tomorrow
sure the vice president always has a
role in advising the president of course
on policy on how
he's communicating to the american
people on a range of issues that are
huge priorities
to this administration and certainly she
will
have a touch in the speech that the
president delivers
tomorrow night i didn't include her only
because i was including kind of staff in
the speech writing team
final question also on the vice
president the president today talked
about
faxing skepticism or hesitancy in his
speech
the vice president that was supposed to
be part of her portfolio and she's done
issue events on that in the past has he
asked her to do anything specific to
help with this problem
vaccine skepticism especially now that
all americans are eligible for the
vaccine
he's asked her to play a leading role um
both as a
person who is very prominent in the
country but and also somebody who has uh
you know experience on the policy front
determining what the right steps are
engaging with the kovic team ensuring
that we are taking the right steps
forward we have a plan that's being
implemented across the country right now
uh a very robust okay
so maybe it's former president lincoln's
ghost so i'm gonna go with that um
a robust plan that's being implemented
three billion dollar
uh focused on getting out to communities
you know she's involved in all of that i
expect she'll be out and doing more
events around the country so the
president's just asked her to
play a leading role in this effort
moving forward which she is certainly
doing
there's nothing specific that he's asked
her to do in the near future
i'm not sure what you mean by that like
what uh maybe kind of psa
or uh you know potentially have some
other sort of vet here
at the white house with groups i don't
know that's what i'm asking you to tell
me
well i i will okay um i think the
president has asked her as the vice
president to be his partner in this and
to be a prominent leader in
this effort to address confidence around
the country she's doing exactly that
he's not going to their conversations
don't involve him directing her to be in
a psa
that happens at a staff level and she is
somebody who travels around the country
she's doing events i'm certain she'll do
psas she'll continue to be involved with
the kova team
with governors with states uh to
continue to reach communities where we
need to increase confidence and that
will continue to be a role she plays go
ahead
democratic lawmakers have been making
the case
that the expanded child tax credit
should be made permanent
they say it's the responsible thing to
do to minimize child poverty
and i was curious what's the
administration's take on why it's
responsible
to let it expire in 2025 well first
there'll be more details we'll confirm
later this evening about what is in the
president's speech and what is in the
american family's plan but
largely speaking the president agrees
that the child tax credit
has a huge impact on helping families
helping reduce child poverty
in this country which we've already seen
an impact of from the implementation of
including it in the american rescue plan
which is something
he did and he also believes that it
helps bring more women back into the
workforce
that's why he has been engaging with
congress and why you'll hear him talk
more about it in the speech
there is also and we'll discuss more
what members of congress want to see
some disagree on this about the length
of time and everything that will be a
part of
discussions there's also a cost it's
about a billion dollars a year
to implement the child tax credit and
uh certainly that's a that is a part of
the discussion that we expect to have
with congress moving forward
yes has the president spoken to the
families of the black men who were
killed in the police shootings in
virginia and north carolina and if not
has the white house had direct contact
with them
uh i don't have any calls from the
president to read out i
certainly i just don't have calls from
the team but i will check on that for
you and see if i can uh
get back to you with more details more
broadly as it relates to india do you
guys have any good understanding of how
many americans
in india right now have become sick with
kova is there any unique precautions
being done to help
bring them here in some form how do you
deal with that and also can you give us
any better guidance in terms of the
diplomatic situation there we believe a
lot of americans
in the consulates and perhaps the
embassy there not americans but the
staff there sure it's all great
questions i would tend to the state
department who will have
more in-depth details about this
obviously we're working very closely
with them but given they oversee all the
consulates they'll have the specific
numbers et cetera
okay how's the state department
is there an update on the iran talks in
vienna it's rob malley back there now
and how long do you think this round
will last
uh so they have been we always expected
their the talks would uh
proceed again uh so rob malley i believe
is either on his way to the region or
there
now uh to uh take part in an additional
round of negotiations
we have felt that even though they're
direct indirect i should say that
obviously a diplomatic process
diplomatic discussions are
the right approach uh and we are uh have
been encouraged by the fact that they've
been continuing
time frame or how long this round will
last do we know
uh i don't think we have a time frame at
this point in time steve but i will
check with the negotiators and see
okay one one thing on the mass mandate
observant college is called out okay you
have a order in place that requires
masks on
all and all federal buildings and all
federal lands
yeah is that being tweaked at all during
today's
guidance on outdoor maps so this was a
great question your colleague in the
back i think asked a version of
um obviously our uh the federal
government will be certainly looking at
the cdc as we
make changes or make implement uh these
policies i just have to check on the
timeline of that
yeah go ahead while we've been in this
briefing
uh the white house someone else in this
building put out
a list of uh nominees including ed
gonzalez the sheriff in harris county
texas
uh to be the uh head of immigration and
customs enforcement do you have anything
to say about that selection or about
where that should be
on the priority list for the uh senate's
consideration
well certainly uh we want we encourage
the senate to
not only consider but confirm qualified
nominees we certainly consider him one
of them
uh but uh the president uh looks forward
to having someone
in place in this position and it it
certainly indicates a priority that
we've put it out today
okay yes go ahead anything where you can
say the president teased to more
information next week in terms of
getting the country closer to normal by
july 4th
what should we expect and in terms of
additional updates or guidance
well we rely on the timeline and the
guidance of our health and medical
experts so i would
i'm not sure they will give you too much
guidelines or too much ahead of time but
the cdc we would wait for the cdc to
provide any additional
guidelines and we'll continue to provide
updates from here
from the president as appropriate as we
get new advice from our health and
medical teams
okay thank you everyone
or maybe they're your camera right
was a little like a ghost though it
wasn't like it was gonna fall it's a
little like
you know spooky